the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones and a
song of ice and fire update video
well my friends it looks like there is
some more breaking news regarding the
game of thrones successor shows
for those of you who don't know i
already uploaded one video earlier today
i wasn't expecting there to be any more
news but i was mistaken
this announcement is fairly significant
if i do say so myself
according to entertainment weekly hbo is
looking to develop
several more game of thrones prequels
including dunkin egg
now before i read any more of this
article i just have to say
i was not expecting this either i think
it was well over a year ago
george rr martin released a statement
where he said hbo would not make any new
shows
based on dunkin egg or robert's
rebellion i believe he did say he wanted
to finish writing more duncan egg
novellas before they went and adapted it
into a television series
you know i i i don't have any plans to
do any of those stories
but i never rule anything out you know
if i get an inspiration or
one of those stories suddenly takes hold
in my imagination and won't let go
sure maybe i'll maybe i'll do something
like that
um one of the things i've been trying to
do with the series is
is to tell these stories tell the
stories of robert's rebellion and some
of the stories of the history of
westeros
in successive revelations and flashbacks
and
people remembering things so at the same
time the story is moving forward
it's also kind of moving backward and
gaps are being filled in
and you're learning and all you hear
about this event in in the first book
and then
you hear a little more about it in the
second book and then the third book
you hear about it from a different
person who has a very different version
of what happened from the
previous versions you've heard and then
there's this hole in it which gets
filled
in the fourth book so i hope by the time
it's all finished
i will have expanded backwards as well
as gone forwards
and many of the many of the gaps will
have been filled in and you'll know more
about the whole robert and
rhaegar and everything like that
but it's not quite the same as telling a
story about them i realized
he also said he did not think it would
make sense for hbo to make a show based
on robert's rebellion because once all
of his books are finished
we will already know everything about
that moment in history
with that being said it seems as if he
changed his mind
if everything in the article is accurate
it seems like entertainment weekly does
have a great relationship with hbo
because they're always getting the
exclusives
so as of right now i will go with what
it says
hopefully hbo officially releases more
details soon
let me show you what it says because
this is very interesting as well
hbo wants to order more game of thrones
successor shows
in addition to the upcoming prequel
series house of the dragon
the network is looking to potentially
greenlight more shows said in the world
of westeros sources say one of which
just reported by variety is a project
based on dunkin egg and early
development
the dunkin egg stories by author george
r martin follow the adventures of sir
duncan the tall
and a young aegon targaryen v
they are set 90 years before the events
in game of thrones
now all of you should already know i
would absolutely love this because it
would most likely mean we would get more
blood raven as well
that's not all hbo has been meeting with
several top writers and throwing out
other ideas based on martin's works
among the ideas being contemplated is a
series based on robert's rebellion
which was the war for the iron throne
that upended westeros a couple of
decades before the events in game of
thrones
one of the writers is a name familiar to
the hbo genre fans
bruno heller who created the acclaimed
historical drama rome
a series that was seen as a bit of a
short-lived precursor to thrones that
said
no writer has yet officially signed on
to any of the series in development
there are no sequels or spin-offs from
the original series currently under
consideration
the idea is for hbo to go big on thrones
for hbo and hbo max in a way
that's not entirely unlike what disney
has done to star wars
disney announced 10 star wars shows
during its investor day conference in
december
and the next day the company's stock
shot up 14
to an all-time high while after thrones
ended in 2019
hbo saw its linear adult demo viewership
drop as it struggled to fill the dragon
size hole in its lineup
hbo's parent company warner media is
investing heavily in hbo max in general
they see the streaming service as it's
you win or you die effort to future
proof the company's entertainment
division
the new move is also similar to hbo's
then unprecedented bake off of making
five different thrones prequel projects
into the development before the series
ended
an operation that ultimately resulted in
one episode being shot that did not move
forward
that was of course the series about the
long night
and another house of the dragon by
co-showrunners ryan condell and miguel
sapochnick
being green led to series this new surge
in development is arguably more intense
however
as it's not just looking for a single
successor but
ideally more than one worthy title to
join house of the dragon on the air
wow like i said before i was not
expecting this
now like most shows that are in the
works they may never see the light of
day
just because they're working on these
does not mean they will get a full
series order like house of the dragon
did
either way they must have done something
to sweeten the deal to get george r
martin to change his mind
now most of you should already know i
would absolutely love to see robert's
rebellion
i think a lot of fans want to see this
series get made
i think it might even have the best
chance of success considering it would
look
and feel so much like the original game
of thrones
now i guess you could also say that is a
double-edged sword there are
also a lot of fans who would hate this
because it would remind them of game of
thrones so much
it could end up just being a reminder of
what happens at the end of season 8.
since we all know that's where the story
is heading anyway i don't agree with
that however just because game of
thrones ended the way it did does not
affect the way i look at future shows
now that dan and dave aren't there i
would like to think things will be done
differently
but none of us will know for sure until
we see the new episodes
the fact that hbo is getting this
aggressive about making more shows set
in this universe has me very excited
i've said it before and i will say it
again i will watch any show adapted from
this amazing world
george rr martin has created i will be
keeping my eyes open from here on out
i want to see if hbo confirms the news
but what i really want to see is if
george rr martin confirms the news
he's the one who said they would not
make anything based on duncan egg or
robert's rebellion
for now i will remain excited as always
make sure you subscribe so you can stay
up to date on any and all information
regarding game of thrones
house of the dragon or any other shows
hbo wants to make
like i said in my last video i will also
let you know whenever i find out any new
information
let me know what you think about these
new developments down below
which of these shows do you want to see
the most as always i want to thank you
all for watching the video
i will see you again very soon bye
[Music]
[Music]
you